with just over three months until
november third president trump floated
the idea of
delaying the election he tweeted
yesterday quote with
universal mail-in voting not absentee
voting which is good
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election in history
it will be a great embarrassment to the
usa delay the election until people can
properly securely and safely vote
question mark hours later former
president obama gave a eulogy at
representative john lewis's funeral in
which he appeared to accuse the trump
administration
of voter suppression there are those in
power
who are doing their darndest
to discourage people from voting
by closing polling locations and
targeting minorities
and students with restrictive id laws
and attacking our voting rights with
surgical precision
even undermining the postal service
in the run-up to an election
that's going to be dependent on mail-in
ballots so people don't get sick
chief washington correspondent major
garrett joins us now major
good to see you uh let's begin with this
the president's two party
leaders rejected this suggestion to
delay the election give us a reality
check here
look the president doesn't have the
power congress does
that's by order of the constitution and
states run our elections this is not
going to happen
and when the white house says oh the
president is only asking a question
grammatically attaching question marks
doesn't change something
that's essentially a declarative
statement vlad if i say to you stand
there
and let me punch you in the face and i
put three question marks after that
that doesn't make it any less menacing
and if you don't want to take my word
for it
take the word of a guy named stephen
calabresi who is a law professor at
northwestern university
he's also co-founder of the federalist
society which is marched in lockstep
with the trump administration
on all federal bench appointments and
vociferously defended him
during impeachment stephen calabresi
wrote in the new york times
that that tweet is by itself constitutes
grounds for immediate impeachment
proceedings
and removal from office he called it
fascistic
so just bear that in mind so should i
read anything into the fact that the
president tweeted this major
yesterday just as the news of the
economy was coming out just as we were
getting
updated covet 19 numbers why is the
president raising the issue now
because he is in a weakened political
position and he knows that if he creates
some doubt
by whatever means of the accuracy or the
verifiability of this election and he
loses
somehow he's not as directly to blame as
he might otherwise be
it is a political tactic but i tell you
vlad
for the last two weeks i've been talking
to election experts around the country
including six different secretaries of
state from both
parties and rhetoric like this creates
for them
a maddening scenario where voters wonder
reasonably what is the president talking
about
what are our systems in our state and
these are serious people
working hard on serious election issues
related to the pandemic
trying to solve them and the president's
tweets do not help them
in their mission the president also
claims mail-in voting is rife with fraud
yesterday during a briefing major you
heard him say he doesn't want to see
a crooked election what are the facts on
mail-in voting
here's one of my sources the head of the
federal department of homeland security
election security division he says to me
you know what mail-in voting is actually
more secure you know why
because there's always a paper trail
machines that's not always the case
and the president previously has said
well foreign nations could print ballots
by the millions and that could distort
things completely false
there are two printers in our country
there's a certain weight
to mail-in ballots there's a bar code
the states that use this system
understand the weighted paper the
machine's rejected if it's not the right
paper
the barcode also matches things up this
is a highly secure
way of voting are there slowdowns in
counting
yes there are and the president if he
wanted to could help solve this
how by sending states more federal money
to assist them in processing and
building out the infrastructure
to handle what will inevitably be in
many states
more mail-in balloting than we've
previously had major let me ask you one
last question
during his eulogy yesterday for john
lewis president obama former president
obama called for the senate
to eliminate this the filibuster explain
to our audience what that means and how
it could change the makeup
of what we see going forward
so if you're the majority party and you
can't find 60 votes right now in the
senate you can't move
your top legislative priorities if you
eliminate the filibuster and have a
simple majority you can
democrats now wondering is it possible
not only
potentially defeat president trump for
reelection but also
take the sufficient number of seats to
gain a majority in the senate
what former president obama is saying is
if you get the majority
you can entertain this rule change and
pass so much of this agenda
who is hearing that most especially
progressive democrats you want to see an
activist agenda
under the biden presidency that is a
clarion call
to motivate get out vote and see what
can happen
major garrett always great to have you
for your reporting and analysis we thank
you my friend